earlier this hour florida governor ron
desantis right there on the show
explaining his decision to send law
enforcement officers to help
out at the borders in texas and arizona
texas republican senator ted cruz sits
on the border security and immigration
subcommittee joins us right now from
orlando florida we'll talk about that
and why he's down there in a moment but
first
senator you know it's a sad commentary
that the federal government
is not patrolling our southern border
and now
the states have got to help each other
because
governor abbott said we need help and
now
states all across the country are said
sending people to your state
because it's a mess well it is
and and it is a complete and total
abdication by the federal government
joe biden and kamala harris are quite
simply not doing their job they're
refusing to enforce the law
and and they've created an unmitigated
crisis at the border
a couple months ago i took 19 senators
down to the border to see
first hand what was happening and i've
been to the border many many times
it is worse than it has ever been we had
just last month over 180
000 people cross illegally last month
we're on pace for 2 million people
to cross illegally and joe biden and
kamala harris have zero intention of
doing anything that's why they won't go
to the border
kamala at this point it's almost like a
comedy show
she's so terrified you know it reminds
me of that old show where in the world
is carmen san diego she'll
she'll go everywhere except the border
uh
because she's afraid of what's going on
down there and they have no solutions
well she she hasn't been to europe
either i hear and then she laughed and
she's laughing it off you know what's
interesting is because it's such a mess
down there
it has been announced by the governor uh
that
he's put a down payment of 250 million
bucks on
having the state of florida finance your
own wall
yep look i think it is a very good thing
that we're seeing the state stepping up
we're glad to always welcome law
enforcement whether from florida or
other states to come to texas
and i'll tell you the state of texas has
been leading when it comes to securing
the border for a long time i'm glad that
we see the governor in the state
legislature
investing and finishing the border wall
but but for years we've had texas
department of public safety
officers patrolling the border i've been
out on them and i'll tell you you know
what's crazy
the texas dps has better equipment than
the feds their boats are better their
planes are better i've been up in the
dps plane it's got incredible infrared
technology
where you can it can go eight miles away
and you can spot i've been up in the air
and you can spot and they'll say okay
there are two or three coyotes
there's a group of illegal immigrants
they're getting ready to smuggle across
and what they do is they call the
customs and border patrol agents and say
all right
they're crossing right here and when you
have uh
border patrol agents able to do their
job they can stop and intercept them
that's right if they choose to do it and
that's uh that's a rub right there yeah
uh
now you are in a hall right now in
orlando because
uh coming up at 11 o'clock this morning
you are speaking at the faith and
freedom
coalition's road to majority conference
which is streaming this weekend on
fox nation for fox nation subscribers
what are you going to be talking about
senator
well i'm going to be talking about the
need to defend america that we're seeing
an assault
on our foundational principles we're
seeing an assault on our constitution
and bill of rights we're seeing an
assault on our founding fathers and the
principles
that built america we're seeing an
assault on our sovereignty
with the border not being defended and
and today my
remarks are really a call for american
revival a call for us to stand up and
defend our nation
there are angry forces on the left that
want to tear down
all of the pillars of american democracy
and we've got to answer the call and
we've got to stand
up and and defend this great nation well
you've got a busy day thank you very
much for spending a little time with us
here at fox and friends